foreign
brochure
Brothers
additional
uh foreign
foreign
listen
yes
foreign
Commission
thank you very much
to be here on the 9th of May
the 9th of May is
[Music]
to remember the lessons
so it is
[Music]
the 9th of May Europe
um
[Music]
in Russia Putin and his regime have
destroyed these values
but now they are attempting to destroy
them here in Ukraine
because they are afraid of the success
you represent
and the example you show
and they are afraid of your path to the
European Union
but the aggressor has already
dramatically failed
Ukraine has resisted the attack
and is fighting back successfully
and why that
first and foremost because as a free
Society
Ukraine Can Count On The unquenchable
Bravery of its million women and men
they fight for our European values
while the Invaders have been dragged out
of prisons and picked off the streets to
be sent to the front line
in this fight
the European Union and its member states
stand shoulder by shoulder with Ukraine
the 9th of May also symbolizes something
else
and that is solidarity
a solidarity born out of the lessons of
the great conflicts of the 20th century
that is the spirit of our democracies
and dear president zielinski I am here
today to assure you
that you can count on that very same
solidarity for as long as it takes
we have a very good discussion
we're working on different strands and
let me report off from some of them
the first priority is to help to secure
the ammunition Ukraine needs
you know that we are working along three
tracks
the fastest track is the immediate
release of ammunition from member states
stocks
we have allocated 1 billion euros to
this and it is working
significant stocks of ammunition have
been delivered or are on their way to
Ukraine but more needs to be done
urgently
therefore the second track we agreed
last week
provides 1 billion euros from the
European peace facility for the
procurement of 155 and 152 millimeter
ammunition by member states
and to accelerate this work
the third track will help the member
states to ramp up the production scale
up the production and speed up the
delivery of ammunition to meet ukraines
and the member states needs
the second topic is financial support
we continue our Vital financial support
to Ukraine
you know that we have an 18 billion
package for the whole year of 2023
of which we have already dispersed by
now 6 billion euros
this is contributing significantly to
closing Ukraine's budgetary Gap but of
course we are already working on
financial support Beyond 2023
the third topic has been mentioned the
sanctions
we continue to do everything in our
power
to erode Putin's War Machine and his
revenues
our sanctions are working
and we reduced for example our imports
from Russia by nearly two-thirds
thus depriving Russia of crucial revenue
streams
so we have already imposed a heavy price
on the Kremlin
through the 10 successive sanctions
packages
now last Friday the commission adopted
its proposal for the 11th sanctions
package
the focus of this package is now on
cracking down on circumvention
we're doing this in very close
coordination with our International
parties partners
particularly with the G7
and let me deep dive very briefly on
three elements in this package
first we are sharpening our existing
tools
so we are adding more products to our
Transit ban
for example Advanced Tech products
or aircraft parts
that are going to third countries via
Russia will no longer end up in the
kremlin's hands
however we will need to take additional
action
we recently see a growth of Highly
unusual trade flows between the European
Union and certain third countries
these Goods then end up in Russia
and this is why secondly
we are proposing a new tool to combat
sanctioned circumvention
if we see
that goods are going from the European
Union
two-third countries and then end up in
Russia
we could propose to the member states to
sanction those goods export
this tool will be a last resort
and it will be used cautiously following
a very diligent risk analysis and after
approval by EU member states
but there should be no doubt that we
work against sanctions circumvention
and the third element in this package is
we propose to ban Shadow entities from
Russia and third countries who are
intentionally
circumventing our sanctions
so far in the 11th sections package
the fourth work strand we have been
discussing
is beyond the war
and let me touch upon the future
and Ukraine's path towards membership of
the European Union
the commission clearly set out seven
steps that Ukraine needs to take before
the commission can recommend to member
states to launch the accession
negotiations
Ukraine is tirelessly and intensively
working on these seven steps despite the
difficulties of carrying out reforms
amidst a full-blown world
so I want to pay my deep respect for
this outstanding work
you know you can count on our support
and our expertise throughout the whole
process work needs to continue
so the commission will report to the
council indeed first orally in June but
most importantly then in writing in
October
dear president zielinski you mentioned
the grain topic this is a challenging
situation and we need Solutions
the immediate priority now is that the
grain Transit goes seamlessly and at the
lowest possible cost outside from
Ukraine towards the European Union
this requires a very close cooperation
of the different stakeholders therefore
we will jointly set up a coordination
platform
so that we will get the solidarity Lanes
fully functioning again this is
important
Ukraine has been fighting for the ideals
of Europe that we celebrate today
to create lasting unity and peace
to represent the values of freedom
diversity
and Humanity that Europe is built on
and we should never forget that peace in
Europe
seemed
impossible
improbable
and far too distant for much of the last
century
but it was achieved
despite the pain
and despite the divisions of War
as we stand here today in a country
senselessly attacked
some might think it is impossible
improbable or too distant
to talk about a free and peaceful
Ukraine in the European Union
but Europe is about making the
impossible possible
and so is Ukraine Slava Ukrainian
um
thank you very much
Madam president of the European
commission you bet answer will be my
question but I wanted to have your
advice on the progress
Ukraine made to implement these seven
steps
despite the state of War
full-blown War Ukraine is working hard
tirelessly and intensively on the seven
steps a lot of progress has been made
but work has to continue so we have been
discussing the details
um and it is very important that we have
progress but I'm very confident because
we had very good discussions on the
different topics that are being
addressed by these seven steps so our
AIM now is uh to have the oral report in
June but most importantly is then the
written report that has an overview over
the whole Year's progress and this will
be the decision-making element presented
to the member states then in October
foreign
[Music]
assembly
too much
is here
Federation
is
teaching insurance
foreign
on the question uh to the nuclear we are
working very intensively on with our
member states to diversify a way and so
to be independent what that is concerned
this is a hard work but some of the
member states are making progress and
you can rely on the fact that we will
keep pushing our member states
very quick
ly
chocolate